jury selection begins in new york this
morning in r
kelly's federal court trial the r b star
faces racketeering charges
for alleged sexual exploitation of
children
kidnapping forced labor and
transportation of women and girls across
state lines
for illegal sexual activity kelly was
also
indicted in chicago on charges including
child pornography and obstruction of
justice
that case is on hold during the trial
here in new york
kelly denies all the charges against him
joining us now is asante mcgee she lived
with r kelly in 2016
and now accuses him of abusing her and
other women living in that home ahsante
good morning to you
first and foremost when we spoke to you
back in 2019 you said
that you were literally terrified when
you saw that interview that he did with
gayle king
are you still terrified does it still
bring about those emotions when you
see him in court when you hear his name
um it does whenever i hear his voice i
freeze up
i'm trying to get a little better
because i am in counseling
but when i hear his voice i am still
terrified you say that you face
backlash because you did speak out what
has life been like for you since you
went public with your story
in the beginning i did receive a lot of
backlash till today i still receive
backlash but i don't receive
as much as i've done in the beginning as
much as i received in the beginning
right now i'm just trying to live my
life take care of my family
and run both my businesses my non-profit
as well as my hvac business
have you been interviewed at all by
investigators prosecutors here in new
york for this case
no i have not do you think that this
will be different
from the previous uh case back in 2008
when he was acquitted
you think this is a different time for
him
yes i do believe this is a different
time for him simply because of social
media and then so many women
coming forward and having so much more
evidence than it was back in 2008
asante it's tony de coppola i'm curious
what you
would define as success or a positive
outcome from where you're sitting
with this trial what do you want to see
happen as jury selection begins today
um i just want the um jurors to go in
with an open mind to
just really look at all the evidence
that has been presented to everyone that
brought the charges against him as well
as i want the jurors to think about if
it's one of their
daughters mothers or sisters or just a
close family member a close friend as
they
go through the jury selection and decide
on his faith
asante it's vlad duties what do you say
to people who believe
as you used to that because robert has
not been convicted of any crimes
that the accusations can't be true
i had to learn that i guess for me when
i didn't believe the accusation was true
back in 2008
because i couldn't believe that a juror
would actually acquit him if they had so
much evidence
but now actually experiencing it and
knowing that it's not enough money in
the world to get him off this case like
he was able to get off the first case
and one of the things that you've said
is that it's easy for somebody to say
that they never they would never let a
man
mistreat them or abuse them but it's
hard to leave when you don't recognize
the early warning signs can you explain
that for our viewers
um yes um in the beginning i was
actually in
abusive marital situation and so when i
actually started dating
on robert and living with him is when i
started seeing the
abuse and because i was able to
recognize the abuse
sooner than later i was able to escape
so
for a woman we might think it's grooming
us but when you have already been aware
of a previous abusive relationship
then you start recognizing the symptoms
a little earlier to just get out and not
tolerate it
asante i know you and many others said
that you wanted to see
our kelly get help um but he continues
to deny all of these allegations
do you see a world in which perhaps he
may admit to any of the
accusations against him
knowing the robber that i've been
knowing for a while he would never admit
because he seen no wrong in what he'd
done to us
but hopefully sooner than later he will
get the help that he need
and soon once you get the help be able
to recognize
the hurt that he has caused not only
just me but other women in the past
asante i want people to understand the
racketeering case that the jury is being
seated for
today so it the allegation from
prosecutors is
that r kelly ran a criminal enterprise
by compelling his employees to help him
abuse women uh what what was your
experience in the context of that charge
with his team with those employees that
he may have been directing
well when i was actually with him
certain employees they did move us
around
um a lot of some of them agreed and some
didn't agree with
what he wanted them to do with us but i
guess because it was a paycheck they did
what they asked them to do
just to get a paycheck you know asante
he's been charged and acquitted of sex
crimes before
do you think that this time will be
different
oh definitely yes i do believe that he
will actually be convicted of all the
sex
crimes that he's been accused of
well ahsante mcgee thank you so much for
spending some time with us
we're glad to know that you're doing
much better thank you very much
thank you for having me